[SPEAKER_04]: Here we go, okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, this is Gouge.
[SPEAKER_04]: Gouge, on the bridge, sneaking forward towards the torch on the third of well sun, early in the morning.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, so you start walking forward on the platform, crouching, using your hand against the wall to stay where you are.
[SPEAKER_04]: You don't want to be
[SPEAKER_04]: Totally crouched.
[SPEAKER_04]: You want to be able to walk forward, but you test with your foot.
[SPEAKER_04]: So you're going pretty slowly.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: Probably slower than even a half pace.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: So you have a plus two on stealth.
[SPEAKER_00]: So go ahead and roll.
[SPEAKER_04]: And you've got your stone up two, so it's a plus eleven.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: It does your proficiency as well.
[SPEAKER_04]: That goes up as well.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: Seven plus eleven is eighteen.
[SPEAKER_04]: The boards are creaking as you sneak forward.
[SPEAKER_04]: It's not really the best environment to do, but you do a decent job.
[SPEAKER_04]: I think what's more annoying is the voices that you hear behind you.
[SPEAKER_04]: There's some kind of urgency going on with your companions, and it's like hushed whispers.
[SPEAKER_04]: The problem is it echoes off.
[SPEAKER_04]: The caverns.
[SPEAKER_04]: You don't know if this is enough to tell somebody that you're there, especially somebody 100 feet away, but you'd really like it if you were alone right now.
[SPEAKER_04]: That's what it comes down to.
[SPEAKER_04]: How close do you want to get?
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, so I notice hush whispers from behind, but with the sound of urgency.
[SPEAKER_04]: Well, just, you know, just kind of like that.
[SPEAKER_00]: So why wouldn't they be quiet?
[SPEAKER_04]: They are not coming forward anymore.
[SPEAKER_04]: They've stopped as you've requested.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm turning back to see if I see any light or anything.
[SPEAKER_00]: No.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I'm still on boards.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: And you're about, I'd say you're about a hundred feet away from the torchlight.
[SPEAKER_00]: Where the torchlight was?
[SPEAKER_04]: Is.
[SPEAKER_04]: Oh, it is.
[SPEAKER_00]: It's still open.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, so it wasn't a person with the torch that went across and disappeared.
[SPEAKER_00]: There's a torch and I saw a shadow.
[SPEAKER_04]: There's a torch and you saw somebody cross ahead in a passageway beyond that.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'll continue quietly, but taking a pause.
[SPEAKER_04]: How close do you want to get to the light is the question I have for you.
[SPEAKER_00]: I want to get off the boards.
[SPEAKER_04]: That is gonna be right in the light.
[SPEAKER_04]: Right in the light?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_04]: So, I mean, the torch is right at the beginning of the rock.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: So, if you get within 60 feet, well, 40 feet, you'll be in what's called partial shadows.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_04]: It's dim light instead of full light.
[SPEAKER_04]: Right.
[SPEAKER_04]: If you get within 20 feet, you're gonna be in full light.
[SPEAKER_04]: They'll see you.
[SPEAKER_04]: Right.
[SPEAKER_04]: If you're in the darkness, they can't.
[SPEAKER_04]: So you can come within 40 feet.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'll get as close as I can then with staying in the darkness.
[SPEAKER_04]: So you get right outside the darkness and you wait.
[SPEAKER_00]: I listen.
[SPEAKER_00]: Listen that way.
[SPEAKER_00]: Listen back.
[SPEAKER_04]: So you hear voices in the caverns beforehand.
[SPEAKER_00]: From torchlight area.
[SPEAKER_04]: From the torchlight area.
[SPEAKER_04]: And two people talking.
[SPEAKER_04]: And they're humans and they're speaking in common.
[SPEAKER_04]: Now you can't make out what they're saying, but these are not hobgoblins.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: I look back.
[SPEAKER_00]: Nothing?
[SPEAKER_04]: Nobody's coming forward?
[SPEAKER_04]: You've probably been gone for about five minutes.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: There's nobody following you at this point.
[SPEAKER_04]: Now, they did stop where they said they were gonna stop, right?
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm gonna make my...
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm gonna start going back now.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so you turn around and stealth back.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: I want to head towards them because they should be...
[SPEAKER_00]: At least Ty should be on me, or at least close enough, so.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I'm gonna go back.
[SPEAKER_00]: I know there's humans up ahead, doesn't sound, and I can get the bard to hopefully talk to him to see who these people are, or why are there humans up here, is what I'm gonna try to get back to do.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_06]: You can get it from sand and I'm all like, dude, have you salted the water with that?
[SPEAKER_06]: I was doing this before I ever talked to you, and I was like, well, Jude's smart, and I was like, okay, so what would fuck up some water?
[SPEAKER_06]: And I'm all like, okay, silica from Sam, but it's the glassblowers.
[SPEAKER_06]: And I'm all like, so the glassblowers could make this powdery dust that swells up in the water, or anything with gills is gonna get fucked up.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, so...
[SPEAKER_04]: After about 10 minutes... How far is Gouge from me?
[SPEAKER_04]: You don't see him for a while.
[SPEAKER_04]: He sneaks up into the darkness.
[SPEAKER_04]: Even though every once in a while you catch a silhouette of him against the torchlight.
[SPEAKER_04]: It's 100 feet away.
[SPEAKER_06]: Do you want to go up and tell him, Jules?
[SPEAKER_05]: I'm gonna...
[SPEAKER_04]: He already got told.
[SPEAKER_06]: Did he get told?
[SPEAKER_06]: Oh, by the cantrip.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, so after about 10 minutes, you hear creaking on the platform ahead of you.
[SPEAKER_04]: Ahead of me.
[SPEAKER_04]: Basically coming back towards where you are.
[SPEAKER_04]: Do you want to say anything or what do you want to do?
[SPEAKER_05]: No, I want to slightly head towards it.
[SPEAKER_05]: Dagger out.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay, so you pull out your dagger?
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: And start heading towards the...
[SPEAKER_05]: But I keep that cloak over my shield.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_05]: And I'm going to hit towards it.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh, nice.
[SPEAKER_04]: All right.
[SPEAKER_04]: You hear Tyrus coming towards you, and then the sound of a dagger being pulled from his cheek.
[SPEAKER_02]: You wanna fuck with me?
[SPEAKER_02]: I match the sound.
[SPEAKER_02]: Wait, what's coming up behind me?
[SPEAKER_02]: And I'll continue.
[SPEAKER_02]: Can I hear him?
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: What the fuck?
[SPEAKER_06]: There's a giant shark in the water.
[SPEAKER_01]: Don't whisper, guys.
[SPEAKER_01]: Talk in your own voice.
[SPEAKER_05]: I whisper.
[SPEAKER_05]: There's a giant fucking shark in the water.
[SPEAKER_05]: Keep your fucking voice out.
[SPEAKER_02]: Watch it actually catch the quiet whisper.
[SPEAKER_05]: Don't go in the water.
[SPEAKER_05]: Giant shark in the water.
[SPEAKER_05]: What'd you find?
[SPEAKER_05]: Well, that's fucking obvious.
[SPEAKER_05]: Why'd you pull your dagger?
[SPEAKER_05]: Because I didn't know.
[SPEAKER_05]: I wasn't sure it was you.
[SPEAKER_03]: Oh.
[SPEAKER_03]: That's it?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay, there's a shark in the water.
[SPEAKER_03]: Well, the objective is not to go in the water.
[SPEAKER_05]: You should know there's a shark in the water, and I didn't know you were coming back.
[SPEAKER_05]: What's down there?
[SPEAKER_03]: Sorry.
[SPEAKER_03]: Humans talking.
[SPEAKER_03]: All right, we got to get back to...
[SPEAKER_03]: Humans?
[SPEAKER_03]: Get back to... Pheromones.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, pheromones.
[SPEAKER_03]: And the bard go, why are there humans down there talking?
[SPEAKER_03]: Couldn't hear what they were saying, but they're definitely humans.
[SPEAKER_05]: Well, I say we get off this platform, because if we fall off this platform, we're going in the waters where the shark is.
[SPEAKER_05]: Let's all go down there.
[SPEAKER_03]: I mean, shit, we all got bows, right?
[SPEAKER_03]: Or some type of ranged weapons.
[SPEAKER_03]: That'd be kind of fun, kill the shark.
[SPEAKER_03]: But yeah, let's go find out what they're doing.
[SPEAKER_03]: Let's all go.
[SPEAKER_01]: So we... Well, are they still coming?
[SPEAKER_01]: Or are they held up?
[SPEAKER_01]: What's going on?
[SPEAKER_01]: They're behind you, 20 feet.
[SPEAKER_03]: We were waiting for... Oh, so we can see them over there.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, or we can see gestures.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: It's incredibly dark, guys.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, so we... Go back.
[SPEAKER_03]: Get them and bring them up.
[SPEAKER_03]: Tell them that there's humans down there and figure it out.
[SPEAKER_03]: And I'm gonna stay and watch through the torchlight on point here.
[SPEAKER_03]: But get everybody here.
[SPEAKER_03]: We need to come out.
[SPEAKER_03]: Sure.
[SPEAKER_03]: Great.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm the one that's gonna come.
[SPEAKER_03]: I go... You wanna stay on point?
[SPEAKER_03]: You want me to go around?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: Can I get around him on the platform?
[SPEAKER_04]: Do an athletics check.
[SPEAKER_03]: Is that an error?
[SPEAKER_06]: No, just make his ass go.
[SPEAKER_06]: If it's uncomfortable.
[SPEAKER_03]: If it's uncomfortable.
[SPEAKER_03]: And I have him.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'm going around.
[SPEAKER_03]: If I go, you're going.
[SPEAKER_03]: Plant myself against the wall.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is a DC 10 athletics check.
[SPEAKER_01]: Two.
[SPEAKER_03]: A two plus athletics?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_03]: Bus six.
[SPEAKER_03]: Puts me at eight.
[SPEAKER_03]: Eight?
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: My stone help.
[SPEAKER_03]: What's that?
[SPEAKER_03]: The stone help.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yes, it does actually.
[SPEAKER_04]: It gives you a plus one to your proficiency.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: So your athletics is seven.
[SPEAKER_04]: Plus two is nine.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Gouge slips and basically his foot slips off the back of the thing and he like begins to fall into the water.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's grabbed onto you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Dagger, grab him.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you basically try to hold him up, right?
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: You've got to do a strength check.
[SPEAKER_01]: This is a DC 10 strength check.
[SPEAKER_01]: Nineteen.
[SPEAKER_01]: So you grab Gouge, and Gouge is like hanging there.
[SPEAKER_01]: You guys hear a board crack and clatter.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, my God.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then you grab Gouge, stick him to the side of the platform.
[SPEAKER_01]: On the side I need to be on, or the side I already on?
[SPEAKER_01]: The side you need to be on.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: Farwin looks at you and says, funny.
[SPEAKER_01]: Agreed.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh my god.
[SPEAKER_01]: What do you do?
[SPEAKER_01]: Do I need to stick my wand in your ear?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I owe you one.
[SPEAKER_03]: And I continue down to that.
[SPEAKER_04]: You start walking back down?
[SPEAKER_04]: You hear a voice pulling off.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm behind you.
[SPEAKER_01]: Who's there?
[SPEAKER_01]: It echoes off the walls.
[SPEAKER_01]: There's a huge fucking shark.
[SPEAKER_01]: How far away from them?
[SPEAKER_01]: The guys that...
[SPEAKER_01]: These guys?
[SPEAKER_01]: 20 feet.
[SPEAKER_01]: So we all hear this?
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh yeah, you guys hear it.
[SPEAKER_01]: It echoes through the caverns.
[SPEAKER_02]: Folsum, I grab onto Farrowind and say, do you know those guys?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: Mine's strictly just cosmic.
[SPEAKER_02]: Can you please speak for us?
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: Would it benefit us for you to speak for us?
[SPEAKER_02]: It would benefit you.
[SPEAKER_01]: And Merrick.
[SPEAKER_06]: Blow your head.
[SPEAKER_06]: I swear I'm not trying to.
[SPEAKER_02]: Get them to say something.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, speak for us, please.
[SPEAKER_02]: Tell them what to say.
[SPEAKER_02]: Say... Say it's...
[SPEAKER_02]: This is Lord Fairway.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm turning and going back while he says that, because I don't want to leave him now.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm being held prisoner by Agents of Lord Jameis.
[SPEAKER_01]: Cover your mouth.
[SPEAKER_05]: You hear clatter behind you.
[SPEAKER_05]: Fucking go!
[SPEAKER_05]: Go!
[SPEAKER_05]: I'm going down the bridge.
[SPEAKER_06]: We don't want to fight on the edge of a cliff.
[SPEAKER_05]: Fucking go!
[SPEAKER_06]: I yell that out loud.
[SPEAKER_01]: Fucking go.
[SPEAKER_06]: And I use my wand and I blow the Toli's head off.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Let's do the head for the torches.
[SPEAKER_01]: So basically, Jude takes his wand and casts a spell.
[SPEAKER_01]: Just toss him to the shark.
[SPEAKER_01]: And blows the guy's head off.
[SPEAKER_01]: Roll damage.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh.
[SPEAKER_01]: Three, four.
[SPEAKER_06]: A's, 9, 10, 11, 12, 13.
[SPEAKER_06]: That's 13.
[SPEAKER_01]: So, basically you see Jude, and let's take the pink eye off, hit the guy in the ear.
[SPEAKER_05]: No, it's the green one.
[SPEAKER_05]: It's the green one.
[SPEAKER_05]: Sorry, yeah, it's this one.
[SPEAKER_01]: With a magic missile and throw him off the edge.
[SPEAKER_01]: Right?
[SPEAKER_01]: And I yell, Go!
[SPEAKER_06]: I've been hanging out with you for a long time.
[SPEAKER_03]: This ain't good if he's fucking yelling at me to go.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay, so, Tyrus, you just...
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you want to take your shield off so you can actually see the ground?
[SPEAKER_01]: Or what do you want to do?
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, the cover's off the shield.
[SPEAKER_05]: I'm running down the thing as fast as I can to get off this bridge.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay, and you're going to follow?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: Now, so those guys are heading forward.
[SPEAKER_01]: The pink guy is gone.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, no, no.
[SPEAKER_01]: Green guy.
[SPEAKER_01]: It was right here.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh, he's gone.
[SPEAKER_01]: He's gone.
[SPEAKER_01]: The pink one is Folsom.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm sorry.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_01]: That was Fairwind.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's Fairwind.
[SPEAKER_05]: That's Folsom.
[SPEAKER_01]: Folsom, and then we've got the other people behind him.
[SPEAKER_01]: Paul Barrow is next.
[SPEAKER_01]: Then there comes Jude.
[SPEAKER_01]: This doesn't make sense.
[SPEAKER_01]: And then there is Merrick.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm going to reset the audio.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm going to get a beer, and then we're going to start doing battle.